- How do you manage your chill?
- Uh, realizing we're
all gonna die someday.
- Well that stresses me out.
- In the past week you worried
about the distant future.
That's just vague enough
to cause me to worry.
- In the past week you were worried about
whether you made a stranger angry.
It's like I don't give a
*beep* about a stranger.
- Right.
- I'm sure I made a stranger angry
but I'm not worried about it.
- Oh.
- Do you worry about
your credit being stolen?
Or your identity being stolen?
- I mean, as long as you
check your credit card bill
every month, you're okay, right?
- Probably not.
- Do you have fake arguments in your head?
- Oh, all the time.
- Okay.
- Oh yeah.
- Glad I'm not the only one.
- I was thinking, I
like to plan out exactly
what I would say.
- You've made someone call
you when they got home
from visiting you to make
sure they got home okay?
Yeah, that's just basic safety.
- You're not afraid to poop
in the public restroom.
- Like what's gonna happen?
- Like you made a really loud fart.
Then someone's gonna go like woah,
I'm gonna remember your shoes
so that I can make fun of you later.
- Literally I called my mom this morning
to try and plan Thanksgiving vacation.
- It's July.
- Flights get expensive real fast.
- Can we just compare out
front pages real fast?
This is my front page.
- I don't want to mark something.
- That's his.
- You've called someone and
then immediately followed
with text, who hasn't?
Mom, pick up my mom phone calls.
- I like how the last person
says you're worried you'll
get a high score on this quiz.
I definitely checked that off.
- I mean people, I think,
get a lot of anxiety
and a lot of really stressed out
about what other people
are thinking about them.
As soon as you're not talking
to somebody face to face,
they're not thinking
about you at all anymore.
- I tend to reach out
to people who I trust
and I like express my thoughts.
- Turn the negative into a positive.
- And don't get stuck on the
things you can't control.
I think that's the biggest thing is...
- Yes.
- You still gotta be you and care
and stress out, good stress,
about things.
- To be able to, as Taylor
Swift said, shake it off.
- Here's one thing.
People say I take too long in board games.
But I also rarely lose.
Think about that for a second.